a group of Choral Academy students are
at the helm of a new business program
and they're looking to expand their
reach to students throughout the valley
Candice Charles joins us live from The
Newsroom with how it all got started
good morning Candace Good morning Sherry
good morning folks well the business
Club students at the Sandy Ridge Campus
saw a need and wanted to help fill it
first they had to find the money to do
it so they applied for a city Grant the
youth neighborhood association
partnership program Grant receiving
12.50 they started a free five-week
Business Essentials program teaching 7th
through 10th graders from their school
choral Academy and some from low-income
schools throughout the Valley hospital
and Hospital excuse me and tourism
marketing entrepreneurship business
administration and most importantly
Finance
how are people who are passionate in
finance supposed to know their
passionate and finance without Finance
classes we really need financial
literacy for teens and maybe
implementing these programs into schools
making sure all kids have access to it
it would be like just wonderful
yep that is the future guys and the
students tell me this is just the
beginning they plan to apply to the ynap
grant again in August with the hopes of
expanding to more students more
low-income students as well throughout
the Valley now this is the last week of
the program but you can still bring your
child it's tomorrow and Thursday night
at the Cox Innovation lab from 5 to 6 30
PM we'll have additional details on our
website newsnow.com